and I remember I went on some dates last  year  um through a couple I went to a couple  girls I met from Bumble and one of them  she said that she would choose the place  we'd go because I was driving to her  yeah and I got she got in my car  and she gave me a post coaching made up  because she hadn't made any plans and  rather than tell me she hadn't made any  plans she gave me a postcode she'd made  up oh man and so I was putting it into  the sat nav and this wasn't coming up  and I was like what this postcode  doesn't exist and then she just made up  some light and about two hours later she  tells me that she hadn't made plans  since she'd learned stuff and instantly  I just went  how am I ever going to trust this girl  if she's going to lie about something so  basic the very first time I met her and  that was it